those joining us on the stream we'll
just give that a second to boot in
welcome to this meeting uh the final one
in this term in this training for the
performance policy and Partnerships
committee uh we have an apology a late
apology from councilor Alan Arnold and
just to recognize that on Zoom we have
councilors Abbott crackett and uh Mrs
coote as well welcome along
um just if I'm not aware of any other
apologies we're all
that's everyone
um before we start in the absence of any
items of public forum Mr mcfar has
something he'd like to update us on with
regards to this coming Monday and the
memorial service
welcome Richard
um I just want to take five minutes of
time just to share some information
which has already been released in the
media today
uh regarding uh the 20 Monday the 26th
the Memorial Day for the passing and
morning of Queen Elizabeth II uh we have
will be live streaming the Wellington
State service at the Civic Theater and
this is an opportunity to provide uh
accessibility for our wider Community to
come together to mourn together it is
not a Civic event I just want to clarify
that so it is a uh a broadcast of
another Civic event which means uh
tikhanga the pro the uh
order of events anything will all come
out of the Wellington service we won't
have any input into that we also won't
have any speaking opportunities to keep
it nice and clean and clear
it will be broadcast at 2PM with a start
Outdoors open at 1 30 and
to the building there is a one minute
silence so there will be a lockout at
the beginning so anyone attending if
they're late they will be locked out for
that one minute silence other than that
it will be come and go as you as you
please free of admission you don't need
to register or anything like that but
there won't be an opportunity for any
speeches or anything as it will simply
be the screen on the um the Civics so
we're not sure of the appetite for this
but I I believe it's um there'll be
enough to fill the Stalls at least so
we're anticipate installed only event
just a place for people to come so happy
to answer any questions that anyone has
for clarity thank you Richard questions
counselors
if not commend you for making the
opportunity available for people and
hopefully a little extra publicity from
this exposure or counselors may choose
to join in as well on Monday thanks
Richard
councilors are neglected to get him over
and seconded for the apology
councilor pottinger and seconded sorry
councilor scalp thank you put that all
in favor
Kerry brings us to the report from the
invercargill youth Council and Katie and
Kayla welcome along
foreign
a chance to read through the report but
this is really your chance to speak to
it add anything that you feel is
relevant and um as if the councilors
have any questions
we have a slideshow made up excellent
just wait for that
It's Kayla Barker and I'm Katie Dennis
and we're from the youth Council and we
were selected to get to Wellington for
three days for the Festival of the
future
um over these three days we're able to
attend a variety of workshops and meet
lots of inspirational people in yeah so
just adding on to what Kayla said um we
got to meet uh someone who flipped to
the next slide
awesome thank you
um we got to meet some pretty awesome
people with some amazing Stories one
thing I took away from it
um from Dave actually was
um finding your why and finding the
reason as to why you do things so I
found that very motivating very
inspirational and it's something that I
will take and share with others and my
peers
um we also got to attend um some
workshops uh one was the sharesies
workshop where we got to learn about
um making investments in businesses yeah
so I'm excited slide please
um what we want to do with what we got
out of this Festival well the first
thing we did get out was we were able to
talk to one of the people that we found
at the festival and she was one of the
organizers of the event and we managed
to talk to her and she asked what we
would want the event to do and we asked
if we would love for it to come down to
the Southland regions in many workshops
kind of in like that invercargill
um because we definitely think the other
people of the youth Council who didn't
get the same opportunity we did and even
people all over invercargill and
everywhere else were definitely
um
loved this opportunity so yeah yeah
another thing that we would like to do
is that while we were up there we had a
lot of um talking and communication with
other youth councils
um one thing we found that would benefit
the Southland youth cup the invercargill
youth council is the opportunity to
hopefully do more meetings over a month
we currently have one a month and we
would love the opportunity to do
um maybe one every week or one every two
weeks this would benefit us hugely as it
gives us an opportunity to catch up more
make more happen in our community and
yeah just truly have more opportunity to
do things
yeah yeah yeah
thank you with the suggestion of
increasing your meeting uh frequency
um
certainly my personal opinion is a
fortnight would be really good but do
you think you would have enough
um agenda topics to to get down to a
weekly or would there be a risk of time
commitment
um perhaps rolling some people out
personally I I find that it's not so
much
um like we would it's not so much about
gender topics it's about getting out in
the community and the youth Council
being seen and we would love the
opportunity to reach out communicate
with the community get more people
involved in the youth Council and yeah
and yeah I agree with it I feel like
already in our hour and a half we do
here once a month we are pushing it with
that time and having an extra hour and a
half once more time a month would be
really beneficial to get out of the
community so the other activities you're
talking about is really Outreach yeah
definitely truly oh cool okay counselors
any further questions
councilor partinger
I guess it's not a question I just
support you that um The increased
frequency is a good thing I mean our
Council itself is going from a six-week
cycle to a four week cycle and we're
getting shell ads more done
I'm sorry
[Laughter]
technically is right
another thing to mention was that I was
at the election Forum the a couple of
weekends ago weeks ago no weeks ago
um so if you have any questions or
anything about that I'm happy to try and
answer
counselors any questions counselor scalp
thank you through Uchi I was intrigued
to look at the audience and the
demographic of the audience you've got
any thoughts around that because there
possibly would have been
I think I counted maybe six under the
age of 20 there
yes some thoughts around that um we
truly did try to get lots of um people
there lots of people youth there
um I think it's I don't know we just
need to find a way to get more people
involved and
um I don't know we're here to come up
with something that makes people
interested in coming
well you try and you had an interesting
way of of introducing the evening as
well so you know yeah we truly thought
it was successful so yeah
yeah we're from [ __ ]
um
with your consent Mr chair
I want to say
that you've come up against the very
dilemma that we all face
um even as more mature people is trying
to get people engaged in local
government and what we do the only time
they want to feed back to us is when the
rates go up or there's a pothole in this
street
well that's how it seems like sometimes
so I I do sympathize the fact that you
struggle to get a lot of more people but
I do think that if you do increase your
frequency of meetings to fortnightly and
some of those are Outreach meetings that
you're doing activities at other Qatar
or at
um other locations where people may not
be constricted for coming because
they're not
you know uh it's a it's a more open
space that you might start to build up a
following if I if I could put it that
way that rather than meetings which can
seem to be a bit dry and process driven
and you know do I really want to find
out about the um you know the parking
policy or whatever it is but if you're
talking about things
such as the council talking about the
smoking policy come along and have your
say we've got our views but we'd like to
hear yours those sorts of opportunities
I wonder if that might work for you but
thank you for the
strength of your input because I have
appreciated my interaction with you this
year and
um if we could clone you and make three
or four hundred more of you
um perhaps the activation rate might be
higher but I do congratulate you and
your fellow members on what you have
done during your term because I know
it's not easy
thank you thank you councilor sober
I was just going just going to ask the
two representatives of
increasing the meeting
are you thinking and doing that of
inviting in more outside speakers on
topics that might
generate some more interest in youth
Council activities
yeah I feel like there would be quite a
good idea but um it's not up to us it's
up to the people making the agenda and
yeah all that but I particularly
appreciate all the people coming and
talking to us differently yeah
definitely we would appreciate it yeah
just thinking of the um festival for the
future you went to and the range of
topics the year that you might be able
to usefully use as a as a bit of a lever
and and I know we've discussed it before
with other youth Council Representatives
the whole area of getting a wee bit more
education for young people about how
local government and central government
functions and so forth so I'm just
thinking it might help to focus some of
your extra meetings yeah to me
thank you thank you any other questions
or comments counselors
if not Katie and Keller thank you very
much for taking the time to leave school
early and come along this afternoon and
present and speak to your report we
really appreciate it and pleased that
you had a good time at the Futures forum
thank you
so councilors um I'll move that we
received that report
Ed by councilor Soper or put that all in
favor
against carried
moves us on to the minutes of the
performance policy and Partnerships
committee from August 9 if somebody
wants to move councilor Scout Reverend
cook
questions or comments
there are none I'll put the motion all
in favor
aye
against
carried
uh councilor Lewis meeting of the
community well-being fund committee from
August 11. thank you chair I would like
to move that these minutes be a true and
accurate record and in doing so I'd also
like to do my traditional thank you very
much to the staff who spent a lot of
hours on doing the preparation of these
agendas I like to do that in public
forum so it's not lost in public
excluded thank you
any other questions or comments
if not and thank you for those comments
councilor Lewis I'll put the motion all
in favor
aye against
carried
that brings us to the dog and Animal
Control fund updates and Patricia will
give you a chance to pop up to the big
green cheer
now if it's red
people will consume it with a confuse it
with another show
and look at that little door you just
stepped on
back to the uh adoption of the annual
plan when
um it was raised to our attention that
there were some issues that there was
the potential for some issues with the
animal control fund
as we had said at the time we were in
the process of doing a review that
review has now completed
um
we the scope of that review was to go
back five years and look at the
transactions that had take gone through
the animal control fund or the dog fund
as it started off as
and recalculate whether we thought those
were the correct transactions that went
through there
as it has transpired We Believe
that not all the transactions that
should have gone through that Fund in
accordance with the legislation had
happened
um we have recalculated what that fund
should have had through it
going right up to current day and are
proposing a number of changes be made so
that we can bring the fund up to its
current day that includes
making sure there is an appropriate
allocation since when Council stopped
allocating corporate costs to activities
that there is the direct costs
associated with servicing dogs and
animal control that are included in that
and we have set a basis for making sure
that allocation of costs can continue
going forward
um as a result the 800 000 or 799 000
that was um
the estimated balance at the annual plan
is much lower than that now
based on the still to be audited amounts
the closing balance is now 573
000.
with a forecast after the current
Financial year the 22 23 Financial year
that that will be down to
um I'm sorry 573 for the 22 Financial
year at 383 000.
and that's because of the capital
expenditure
how this fund works is a little bit
different
it funds the cash
balance of the activity so we don't fund
depreciation out of it but we can fund
capital expenditure on these activities
out of the fund so it works a little bit
different to the rest of council
so that's as if someone was working
through the appends appendices one and
two
it's we don't take depreciation into
account but we do take capital
expenditure and in the last year and
coming forward there is to be some
capital expenditure in this area which
will be funded from the fund
is that so thanks Patricia two questions
for me first of all
firstly are we sure now
that the processes for how funds are
allocated within that
are correct yes
have you had any conversation with the
auditor on your way through for them to
check the process and and are they
comfortable or is that something that
you'll face when they're next with us
we'll face that withinix with us this
issue hadn't been raised by audit at any
time coming through
um it was something that we had
identified ourselves and had a member of
the public also identify it to us as
well thank you
councilor pottinger
um first question then I'll see the
audit how come back in 2017 obviously
audit wasn't interested in that because
if you look at the 2017 figures they are
all over the place
so obviously it's not an audit thing
I am not sure why they wouldn't have
looked at this anymore well they seemed
to count our stabilism pencil sharpers
but
from the materiality perspective it
probably was below their materiality
limit wow
okay and the second question was do
these um at the annual plan time back in
June were aware that there was about a
thousand outstanding registration fees
not paid or overdue or so do they get do
they get written off or are they
included in this as a potential income
or arguments with that they're included
from this as potential income though if
any write-off was to happen in
subsequent years that would go through
us next meetings so okay over time so
that is actually included even though we
haven't got it it's in the figures
thanks
Reverend [ __ ] and then councilor Clark
uh thank you Mr you um Patricia
[Music]
Patricia
um because we were unsure of what the
proper balance was
we ended up not adjusting the fees is
that going to have a negative impact at
the end of this year in other words is
the operation of this going to cost
slightly more than we are going to take
in registrations or are we unsure of
that at this point
I think we would be unsure that at this
point we'll have a better feel with it
in the next couple of months what it's
going to look like yeah but potentially
we could
be a little bit short on our income
compared to what her outgoings may be
because we weren't sure whether
um we needed to raise that that is a
that is a risk thank you and if that
occurred Council will have to accept
responsibility for it because it helped
make the rate knowing that there was an
element of Doubt but it's not likely to
be
one would hope a massive figure oh
absolutely Mr chair I just wanted to get
it and to my head what
one potential implication of us not
having made that decision might be
appreciate that councilor Clark yeah
three
um
just the issue of the capex expenditure
which is now a portion to the the new
fund
or the readjusted fund
so let's let's let's have a movement
downward so I get referred to
a differential amount
235 000 so that that means that we've
spent roughly quarter million dollars on
some capital expenditure in 2021-22
that wasn't a portion to this fund so
that left it artificially high so you've
adjusted that so that then begs the
reverse question is at some stage we did
a portion quarter million dollars to
somewhere else
it now should have some relief
indeed said that the balance is coming
through the net debt accounts on the
other side which we believe is the
general net debt account so that would
be through borrowing
not through borrowing through the net
debt account
thank you
any further questions
well counselors I'll take the first
three uh recommendations for a start
which is to receive the update note that
as a result of a review it's been
concluded that historically the fund was
not reflected in the full cash impact of
activity and as a result recalculations
in line with the attachment
um
the committee should recommend be
approved should somebody be prepared to
move counselor sofa councilor scalp it's
open for questions or comments
there are none I'll put the motion all
in favor against Kerry thank you for
that the other two uh for the committee
to recommend to council so this will
come up next week and
um four and five as a result of the
review necessary to recalculate the fund
to correctly reflect the operations of
the activity
and authorizing Council officers to make
the necessary changes as outlined in the
report so that the animal at the annual
report reflects the correct closing
balance of the fund and corporate net
debt account
councilor Edmondson and Reverend Co
questions or comments
there are none I'll put the motion all
in favor
aye aye against
carried thank you for that
Patricia thanks Jillian Trudy that
brings us to the appointment of a
district licensing committee
commissioner
um at the end of petroleum this is a
usual practice which allows us to
conduct like a licensing business
through until the appointment of a
replacement and in this instance we
would be naming councilor Edmondson
who's the current committee chair is
that commissioner that's great
I'm prepared to move oh second any
questions comments
councilor Clark yeah three gee um and I
don't understand so it might be just
some clarification so these
Commissioners require some some level of
training nope not in this instance they
have a process they go through
um through you Mr chair when we do have
commissioner if you had an appointment
of a commissioner who was in the
community there's certain standards that
are outlined in the report that we
expect from that commissioner and they
would go through training but in this
case by appointing uh Council Amazon we
would be she already has that training
and that ability from her work as the
chair of the district licensing
committee I wasn't suggesting that she
wasn't trained I was just suggesting
that we do future
Commissioners come from because I know
that in the last term we've had people
win the cape that they wanted to train
and either have them trained so those
are resource consent hearing okay
which is a different process and they do
absolutely need training yeah I think we
will be sure to heading into the new
term so there are some new councilors
who are going to find a pretty steep
learning curve councilor Keith yeah a
couple of questions uh Mr chair
the 624 a day
seems a heck of a lot of money it's up
to up to hourly rate yeah I see you here
if it's a part day or part of the arrive
at 78 dollars an hour but 640
624 a day is right up there through you
Mr chair apologies counselor that we do
already have to pay that already for the
chair of the committee so the expense is
not an increase on what is set already
and it's in line with other local
authorities across New Zealand in fact
some local authorities are looking at
increasing it
generally an hour a day is it Rebecca uh
generally it's an hour of fortnight that
I get
yeah I was going to say it was 624 a day
that's just about as much as a prime
minister kids per day yeah I just wonder
is that that uh hourly rate or daily
rate gone up over the years has it
to my knowledge it stayed quite static
for some time and it is in line with
other local authorities when staff
checked and and as I say some local
authorities are looking at increasing it
with their commissioners
no I'm just thinking because I was on
the uh District licensing committee many
years ago and we didn't get paid at all
it was a different act the flat was it
yes this is under the 2012 act yeah
okay now I was just gonna say I'd put my
hand up and do it for nothing so I
believe I've got the com the um the
necessary qualifications to do it but
it's up to you
okay any further questions
through recommendations there which I'm
prepared to move serious you can do
ribbon coat
but they're all in favor against carried
thank you for that I need to abstain
from that Vote or
um
so declare an interesting abstain
thank you we can note that brings us
through to the activity report treaty
uh thank you Mr chair so I will take the
reporters read and open the floor to any
questions
so the adjustment to ours with the Civic
admin building no issues that we're
aware of at present treating none great
foreign
counselors
councilor Clark thank you Justin in
relation to uh the upcoming Monday and I
might have missed a meeting so I'm not
sure this has been resolved so when we
have the uh uh dedicated day on Monday
I'll be opening the pool and the library
uh through you Mr chair
um we the the library will be closed on
the Monday and the polls will be
operating on Normal public holiday hours
so restricted hours
thank you
good question thank you for that
counselor Edmondson just a comment
really
um I at attended the
um welcoming communities events the um
event at the library the human library
and the tree planting on Saturday and it
was great to see so many people out and
it was a lovely day so
um and some very enthusiastic new
citizens planting some trees I'm very
proud to be able to say that they can
pop back there in the future and sit
under the tree that they've planted
all right wait thank you for that
other questions or comments
if not would somebody like to move that
the report is received councilor Lewis
seconded councilor Scout thank you
I'll put the motion all in favor
aye against
carried
uh councilors before going into public
excluded I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank you for the chance
to cheer these committee meetings over
the period since it was uh formed we've
really been the ministry of everything
apart from infrastructure
um through the long term plan and annual
plan process and
uh the weight of the other work that we
have to carry out there have been a
substantial number of extraordinary
meetings that have been called
um and I thank you very much for your
perseverance with that and thank the
staff uh for the work that's gone into
making those happen
um there have been questions asked
through the term and uh the staff have
come back with the answers it's not
something that can happen straight away
because we want the right answer not the
quickest answer and if it takes a couple
of weeks as long as it's accurate that's
fine so thank you for that
councilor Lewis thank you chair I'd like
to say thank you for your chair
chairmanship over this time and I'd also
like to make a quick comment since there
will not be another performance policy
partnership meeting
in which the community will be in fund
will be mentioned I'd like to make
special thanks to the community members
of the we'd have had another meeting
since then so I'm not too sure where
that agenda will come up to but in case
it doesn't come we'll come to the next
meeting of this committee I thought that
might not be one not this committee
that we have community members that come
unheriled or unpaid to some of these
committees and I'd like to thank them
thank you
they're being no further uh business and
public I'll move that we go into public
excluded confirmation of the minutes
and the receiving of minutes from the
community wellbeing fund and the
technology one contract variation of the
reasons as outlined seconded by
councilor Kent I'll put that all in
favor
against Kerry thank you for that and
thank you for those who've joined us on
the Stream